Abdul Qadeer Ali had shrapnel blasted
into his chest arm and leg from a car
bomb last month a suicide bomber from
the armed group Al Shabab drove it into
a checkpoint outside Somalia's capital
Mogadishu conflict in Somalia has
dragged on for decades
Iran Israel I don't see any progress a
government is not protecting the people
every day there is a bomb explosion they
are also dozens of fallen soldiers in
Somalia and they achieve nothing
the term is more positive here at the
Somalia partnership forum meeting the
Somali government and its international
partners the day before it started an
Italian military convoy was bombed in
the capital by al-shabaab a US military
base was also attacked
none of the foreign soldiers were killed
and Somalia's government and its
partners say security is improving the
meeting takes place inside popping
issues Green Zone which is a fortified
enclaves inside depends on security /
African Union troops mostly from Uganda
who have paid and have been trained by
the United States and the European Union
but the African Union troops have
started withdrawing due to go within the
next two years
known as Amazon they've already been
here for 12 years who flushed al-shabaab
out of the towns and cities Amazon has
contributed something
to create his environment it means that
Somalia this movie and moving forward
and peace is slowly becoming a reality
Somalia's army is meant to be taking
over these special forces have been
trained by American troops but the
Army's mired in corruption scandals
which sometimes makes donor countries
reluctant to fund it at the meeting
everyone pledged to push on our efforts
continue to ensure that the Somali
National Armed Forces are as capable as
can be and develop not only the
additional numbers needed to ensure the
security in the country but the
capabilities and the enabling systems
that will allow them to perform as
effectively as possible
elections are planned for next year the
attacks keep happening almost every week
civil war broke out nearly 30 years ago
Somalis have been waiting for peace ever
since
Malcolm Webb al Jazeera Mogadishu
Somalia